when did you first fall in love with
programming
i didn't program a lot when i was in
high school but i had a friend who had a
commodore pet and after we saw star wars
he said hey let's make a basic
uh program that does the death star
trench run
and it was just you know simple 2d
graphics and i didn't know what i was
doing so i just helped them out
uh on the math and stuff like that i was
a math and science kid
i was really into uh the hp calculators
of the early mid 70s these were the rpn
they were really strongly built and as
alright goldfinger
instead of gold divinely heavy there's
probably some gold in them too
cold metallization but they were awesome
calculators and they had
all the scientific functions so i was
really into that
so i aimed towards physics um
i was a little late for the i think the
you know the 20th century golden age
and i read a lot of science fiction so i
was like yeah it's on the hyperdrives
and warp drives and
physics was not going to get there
quickly and i
started hacking on computers while i was
studying physics as an undergraduate
at santa clara university and um you
know
i dodged the fortran bullet because i
was in the science department instead of
the engineering department where they
still did fortran
card decks i think they had an auto
collator but
we were using pascal and uh i got one of
the first
portable c compilers uh ports to the
deck many computers were using and i i
fell in love with programming just
based on um you know procedural
abstraction
uh pascal just what now would be
considered old school
like structured programming from the 70s
um nikolas vert
the creator of pascal was a good writer
and a good pedagogue right he
always at eth would do these courses
where it's like build your own computer
build your own compiler build your own
operating system from scratch
yeah kind of and uh i know some people
who are grad students under him and said
he was
um he would torture the students with
things like this custom email system
that had 25 word limit
and uh things like that unfortunately
dodged both the pascal and the fortran
bullets
uh could you maybe uh linger on the
pascal like what kind of programming
language was it
what is it reminiscent of today because
it sounds like
it may have had uh an impact on your own
trajectory
yeah it was in the algol family and
algol was
um you know the big uh successful
uh language design and compiler project
in the 60s
it had a successor called algol 68 which
is ambitious but not as successful
but pascal was kind of wordy procedures
and functions language
it distinguished between functions which
return a value and procedures which
don't which just compute
and you could say that whole algol
family went into ada
um pascal had a second life thanks to
borland with turbo pascal
which was hugely successful uh i think
in large part due to anders helzberg who
then went to microsoft and did
you know c sharp and done that with his
team there has done really well
doing typescript type javascript uh so
yeah there's
there's a lineage here uh but i was
also interested in c in unix by the time
i was an undergrad
because uh people were bringing unix up
on all sorts of hardware i
had some friends who were doing their
own wire wrapped computers 68
20 maybe and i was wire wrapping for my
engineering course um 6809 or something
simpler
building a computer on board and i
wanted to build a more ambitious one and
port unix to it but i picked the wrong
processor i picked the national
semiconductor
ns16032 which was this amazing
you know cisc complex instructions that
computer
and not the reduced instructions that
computers that were just
being contemplated into the mid-80s um
and risk ultimately went out risk one in
some ways it it
dissolved into that you have both now
you have these super scalar
architectures where
like intel has kept probably too much
backward compatibility at the
instruction
level but that's just a there's a front
end that parses that into these you know
these wide internal instructions so
you know the very long instruction word
research that um
was also interesting at the time kind of
became the micro architecture inside the
backward compatible intel but i picked a
national semi chip and it
never got made successfully it was full
of bugs and i never could have brought
it up
but i went on uh out of physics after
three years into math computer science
and like i said i did it because i saw
um i was being sort of
childlike and naive about physics and i
thought meanwhile the valley is go go
for computers the apple
ii right the the pc the intel
um 8086 uh
8088 based pc the ibm you know gave
microsoft the future
for in a somewhat fishy deal
you